[Music]
[Music]
I'm from Norway I'm a teacher I got
interested in chess a couple of years
ago I started playing just to beat my
face
[Music]
[Music]
so my name is Joseph Pepsi I'm 20 years
old and offering grill over New York I
started playing chess when I was 17
years old I'm really excited to play
bags ecology because honestly is like a
role model someone I look up to like
just like the way he thinks
a little nervous because I have never
actually played a game with a
professional 54 and I have never taken
another notations so I need to practice
that today
[Music]
this what makes Magnus specialist world
champion apart from practice a genius in
the best-ever is that he has an
appreciation for the classics in chess
he can recall games this was what Vinick
53 this was covered blanket 29 love love
love love not like an encyclopedia the
fourth value of my life challenge
this challenge comes because of Magnus's
one of his abs called play magnus over
the course of the last year players have
been battling it out against Digital
Magnus on his app where they can play
against him from age 5 to 27
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]